meatball
how do you feel about britney spears
[Music]
hi my name is alicia and today i'm going
to be picking a date based on
their dog i have a cat she is the love
of my life she is my doji cat
doja is the sweetest girl she's very
sassy i
love dogs i am not responsible enough to
have one myself which is why i have a
cat but i love dogs i am a dog person
and i am so excited what i'm looking for
in a match is somebody who is
vaccinated and supports the free
brittany movement i'm not sure if i'm
gonna end up going on a date with a guy
if i'm gonna end up going on a date with
a woman but i'm open and i'm excited
either way
hey how's it going my name is gavin uh
this is my behemoth of a dog hefty i
love hefty because he is got a lot of
personality
i think the number one priority for me
is somebody who can
love and accept this giant the way that
i do
i think she's gonna love him but i think
it'll be like oh my god he's so chunky
bulldog
i think he's a shoe-in to be picked it
doesn't get much cuter than this little
meatball hi i'm jeanine and this is my
dog and wing woman meatball
i got a tattoo of her right here
honestly meatball is a hit
people want to talk to her and then i'm
like you know that's meatball and um i'm
janine
me and meatball both have all of our
shots so
uh we're ready to get out there meet
some people get some smooches
go in be very nice thank you tell her
i'm nice
you got this champ no pressure but it's
do or die this is my love life
hi my name's hannah and i'm here with my
dog penny she's kind of a reflection of
me i'm very independent
and she also is very independent she's
like my my child
so it's really important to me that
whoever i date
loves her as much as i love her she
is my best friend we try and do
everything
together she's kept me sane throughout
the pandemic
i don't know what i'd do without her
penny please don't embarrass me you want
to get me a
date yeah i am ready to meet some dogs
let's go
hi come here
buddy hi dude you are
chunky you are chunky what did i say
this is a solid dog you guys like you
would protect me huh
oh i got the good spot right there if he
sits on people that's how you know that
like he likes him hi my name is hefty
i'm a five-year-old english bulldog i
love going on picnics with my parent
anything outside that involves food i'm
all in for i could have guessed that you
like food dude you're
chewing on your leash like it's a treat
i knew it i knew he'd chewed on his
leash
okay so i love that his name is hefty
because that just makes
so much sense um it tells me that the
owner definitely has a sense of humor
i love bulldogs i just love like i hope
that the owner can't hear me saying this
but i love
ugly dogs not ugly i think
hefty is owned by a hipster and that's
cool i like hipsters
i wore the wrong shirt today didn't i
bye hefty
nice to meet you i hope your owner is as
cute as you
hi baby this is
a cute little sausage
you're so adorable the coat is very soft
a lot of people talk about the soft coat
it's a hit let's learn a little more
about you
hi i'm meatball that's the cutest name
so far cutest name i come on strong
because i'm excited to see you but give
me a few minutes
i'll be asleep on your leg anyway wanna
kiss
oh meatballs flirting with me
what kind of vibes am i getting from
meatball i definitely think that
meatball is probably
owned by a comedian because the name is
hilarious nailed it
i love it when people name their animals
after food
when i first got me paul she didn't have
a name for like three weeks and i would
just call her random things and i
literally was making a meatball pizza
and then i called her meatball
and my roommates at the time ran out and
were like her name's meatball and then
it worked it's great
this seems like the kind of dog who
definitely is gonna give you like high
energy when you need it but also
definitely down to like snuggle and take
a nap too which i like
yes finally meatballs being understood i
definitely think i would vibe with
meatballs owner
this is definitely the kind of dog that
i would adopt you get all the perks of
having a dog but kind of like the energy
of a cat
she's for sure half cat meatball do you
support the free britney movement
meatball wants to free brittany she's
very passionate about it bye meatball
nice to meet you i hear a pitter-patter
of tiny feet
no freaking way bye sweetie oh my gosh
hi my name is penny i'm a two-year-old
cavalier king charles spaniel that's
a really long breed everyone says i act
like a puppy
like my owner i'm up for anything
whether it's an all-day
hike or an afternoon lounging on the
couch i love
naps me too i have lots of love to give
as you can probably tell i can't tell
penny
penny penny she's not focusing
she doesn't pay much attention okay can
you sit come on penny focus
oh you got an itch i don't know that
might have been a fluke let's see she's
always scratching her ears
sit good you guys
she's really itchy should i be concerned
about that i swear she doesn't flee
i feel like penny's owner is a girl i
don't know why
but i just have a feeling i am is your
owner as cute as you
are she's probably cuter than me you can
tell that she's well taken care of well
groomed and these are all
really good signs you guys good job
penny bye penny
i'll miss you all right so i met three
really cute dogs today
first we had hefty the bulldog who was
indeed very hefty
super cute very loving then we had
meatball who was just a total ham i love
meatball
next we had penny who was just the
prettiest girl i've ever seen she was
adorable
okay this is so hard you guys i
loved hefty he was so cute but i just
feel like
he was a little too um how do you say it
rambunctious
is that a word i love the way he waddled
around on his back but you know what he
kind of left me smelling a little like
dogs i own a dog
dogs smell like dogs i can't really do
anything about it i could bathe him but
then he'll smell like wet dog
and i think wet dog smells worse so that
leaves us with penny
and meatball both super sweet dogs i can
tell that they have great owners but at
the end of the day
i think that penny was just a little bit
mellow for me
oh a misdirect if penny wasn't number
one
then it wasn't meant to be i like to
have fun and that's why i'm gonna pick
meatball because meatball was just a joy
to play with a joy to see
and i'm really excited to see who owns
meatball you made the right choice
i'll say it hi hi how are you i'm julian
how are you alicia
nice to meet you nice to meet you too
thanks for picking meatballs she
she had a lot of good things to say
about you oh did she yeah she's
adorable yeah she definitely had a good
time she's a big flirt so she is yeah
trying to tell her
calm down go easy what can i do you know
so what do you think do you want to go
on a date
yeah i'd love to meatball's crying so
she would also love to all right
we're on our way to get some juice and
we got our buddy with us
all right here we are we're on our date
uh meatball is
big chilling and one other person
complimented meatballs so
that is true somebody was trying to
swoop in on the girls
it's been a fun time you guys yeah good
time on our date um
definitely feeling like i picked the
right choice meatball is a winner
that was a good one cheers to me paul
[Music]
cheers
[Music]
you